Вітаю Ласкаво просимо Ми раді що ви
приєдналися до нас у це важко повірити
війна в Україні триває вже 15 місяців
останнім часом російські окупанти
зосереджують свої атаки на містах на
сході країни
сьогодні від бахмута практично нічого не
залишилося окрім руїни місто зруйноване
бомбами та ракетами
колись тут мешкало понад 70 тисяч людей
але після тривалих запеклик боїв між
російськими та українськими військами
Бахмут перетворився на місто привид
руйнування спричинені війною також
помітні і на півночі України у селі
Лукашівка де російський солдат отримали
відсіч залишилися сліди руйнувань
однак мешканці не втрачають ні духу ні
мужності
Надія Іванівна вірить у відновленні
свого села і вона отримує допомогу від
молодих українців які насправді частина
техносцени в Києві
але коли у них є вільний час вони
спрямовують свій творчий потенціал на
Новий проєкт відбудову
чи який красень
це царство Надії Іванівни
64-річна жінка все життя прожила у селі
Лукашівка на півночі України
Бачиш які яєчка
Коко
На початку березня 2022 року в село
вторглися російські солдати багато людей
загинуло більшість будинків і машин були
зруйновані
будинок Надії Іванівни дивом уцілів під
час обстрілів лише в Сарай влучив
танковий снаряд але вона не може забути
цей жах
звісно є таке що боїшся що вночі ляжеш і
не прокинешся
бо може прилетіти і все є страх Вона
живе зі своєю 96-річною тіткою є ж
бабусю і жуй
сьогодні вони чекають на гостей зі
столиці Києва
Заходьте мої золоті заходьте
ці молоді волонтери приїжджають майже
кожні вихідні щоб допомогти у
відновленні села
Іноді вони привозять із собою їжу та
напої такі вечори дарують Надії Іванівні
надію
я подумала де ж ті золоті діти взялися
для нашого села
раніше ж такого не було Ніхто Так нам не
допомагав не приходив
[музика]
у цьому селі особливо радіо волонтерам
адже держава наразі не в змозі розпочати
відбудову приватних будинків
якщо намагатися вірити у прекрасне в
хороше не намагатися це подарувати людям
не спробувати виправити щось Що
відбувалося погано то це повний
Це дійсно правда
Наступного дня вони вирушають на
будівельний майданчик
Надія Іванівна спускається вниз щоб
дістатись підвалу припаси під час
російської окупації яка тривала три
тижні вона переховувала тут своїх дітей
та онуків але їх спіймали каже Вона
і поставили їх поставили ось тут у
шеренгу на коліна а тут вікна побиті тут
скло було і все на світі Онука мого всіх
в старшому онуку Дімі порізали обличчя
кинджалом
Інна наступний день повели його до
церкви щоб застрелити
але вона сказала що його залишили у
живих бо йому ще не було 18 років
[музика]
Надія Іванівна щосуботи ходить до церкви
щоб помолитися за своїх рідних
церква Вознесіння Господнього Була майже
повністю зруйнована обстрілами
а воно як почало вибухати начебто атомна
бомба була
тут російські окупанти зберігали
боєприпаси допитували полонених і
розстрілювали людей
[музика]
волонтери з Києва знають як важко тут
було і тому хочуть допомогти і серпня
Вони побудували шість будинків
будівельні матеріали надали
бізнес-партнери та фонди фахівці навчили
їх як правильно все робити
Вони знають що все це знову може бути
зруйнованим якщо будуть нові атаки
ми розуміємо що війна може в такому
режимі тривати ще кілька років
якщо знову доведеться відбудовувати
будемо відбудовувати досвід уже маємо
[музика]
помічникам час повертатися до Києва але
лише після того як бабуся Надія вручить
їм величезну банку солоних огірків За
їхню важку працю
Кай вас Господь береже
щасливою вам дороги і як приїдете вже в
Київ подзвоніть мені
довкола життя диких тварин ведеться
брудний бізнес знову і знову рідкісні
види що охороняються цей орангутан
незаконно переправляється в інші країни
у валізах або в контейнерах кораблями чи
літаками
багато тварин гине в муках під час
подорожі І лише деяких виявляють митники
валіканте Іспанія ці офіцери повинні
бути особливо уважними Іспанія стала
гарячою точкою Європи для контрабанди
диких тварин знахідки часто шокують а
контрабандисти зазвичай на крок попереду
інспекторів
її серце Все ще в дикій природі але
тепер Кенія живе у вольєрі в іспанському
притулку для тварин поблизу Аліканте
Саме ці димчастої пантери всього 11
місяців але вона пережила чимало
страждань
доглядальниця baliday виходжує її та
допомагає відновити здоров'я
її конфіскували у приватного власника
який нехтував її вочевидь від самого
початку поганогодували і вона навіть
осліпла
тепер приватний заводчик має постати
перед законом за порушення Конвенції про
міжнародну торгівлю видами дикої фауни і
флори що перебувають під загрозою
зникнення згідно азіатська димчаста
пантера також знаходиться під загрозою
зникнення тому Кенія дуже рідкісна
це так засмучує зазвичай ці тварини
мають дуже хороший зір нам довелося
спеціально обладнати вольєр пандусами бо
інакше вона не могла б знайти різні
рівні ті леопарди живуть на деревах їм
потрібні перепади висот щоб правильно
розвиватися
Іспанія стала воротами для нелегальної
торгівлі екзотичному видами тварин
Поліція часто знаходить їх під час
огляду кораблів що прибувають вволіканти
із сусіднього африканського континенту
Марія пелісер працює у спеціальному
підрозділі з боротьби з екологічними
злочинами
у багажі пасажирів тут і в аеропорту
вона знаходила птахів змій і черепах
це так сумно ці бажані люди без жодних
докорів сумління виривають цих тварин з
їхнього середовища існування і
поводяться з ними як з іграшками
це Поліцейські відео зняти у вересні
2021 року показує звільнення самки
шимпанзе яку 5 років утримували у клітці
на самоті
нелегальний імпорт охоронюваних тварин
зростає у 2022 році контрабанда в
Іспанію зросла більш ніж удвічі
порівняно з попереднім роком
часто за цим стоять організовані
злочинці
щоб знайти тварин потрібні контакти в
країні походження А щоб їх імпортувати
потрібна мережа в Європі
це дуже прибутковий бізнес
мавпа наприклад Два Африці може
коштувати 5-6 євро А тут вона може
принести 2000 євро і більше
за даними Всесвітнього фонду дикої
природи цей глобальний бізнес оцінюється
у мільярди
Silvia DS каже що нелегальна торгівля
тваринами посідає третє місце після
торгівлі наркотиками та зброєю але її
вплив недооцінюють
до торгівлі зброєю та контрабанди
наркотиків ставляться більш серйозно до
боротьби з ними докладається більше
зусиль
нелегальна торгівля тваринами не менш
серйозна але вона так не сприймається а
винних не так активно переслідують і
притягують до відповідальності це робить
ці злочини ще більш прибутковими
але Влада часто не в змозі боротися із
торгівлею екзотичними тваринами
ця макака ймовірно була переправлена із
Марокко до Іспанії але контрабандистам
вдалося завести сліди
торговці використовують нові технології
продаючи тварин через інтернет
Їм вдається уникати покарання оскільки
вони можуть ховатися за анонімними
мережами
вони навіть використовують даркнет
Влада немає достатньої кількості
фахівців для належних розслідувань її
тварин часто рятують коли вже занадто
пізно як у випадку з димчастою пантерою
кенією
А вона занадто звикла до людей і вона
Сліпа
у дикій природі вона Ніколи б не змогла
поладнати собі подібними
вона виросла в неволі тому Приречена на
таке життя
незаконна торгівля перетворює кенію та
багатьох інших диких тварин подібних до
неї на товар який назавжди втрачає
свободу
Швеція незважаючи на свою блискучу
репутацію за кордоном насправді може
бути небезпечним місцем для життя рівень
вбивства зростає протягом багатьох років
і навряд чи є інша країна в Європі деги
настільки людей внаслідок перестрілок
часто це злочини пов'язані з бандами
деякі з яких можна побачити На власні
очі на околицях Стокгольма в бідних
житлових районах таких як Рігбі
це район Незабаром буде з'єднаний мостом
сусіднім Усиком і це викликає
стурбованість
війни між бандами перестрілки тримають
Швецію в напрузі вже кілька років
ситуація стає дедалі напруженішою
передмістя де живуть переважно мігранти
часто опиняються у центрі уваги такі
передмістя як лінкбі на півночі столиці
Стокгольма
Стефан ліндстроум має план для Рігбі
міст для кращої інтеграції мешканців
міський планувальник ініціював
Будівництво споруди але Думки щодо цього
пішохідного велосипедного мосту
розділилися
з одного боку лінкбі там багато людей
мігранського походження з низьким рівнем
доходів і освіти а з іншого боку урсвік
район де живе середній клас із хорошою
освітою
ці два райони
бізнесмен Алі ерин підтримує цю ідею Він
вважає що міст допоможе інтегрувати його
район рікві у місто він стурбований
зростанням рівня насильства і каже що
держава повинна докладати більше зусиль
одними мостами цю ситуацію не вирішити
у школи майже не вкладають гроші
натомість все більше шкіл
приватизовується і закони надто м'які
молоді люди знають якщо їм немає 18
років у них б'ють когось то Максимум що
вони отримують 2-3 роки в'язниці Це
катастрофа
раптово нашого розмову перериває якийсь
юнак і починає погрожувати ерино але РН
вміє постояти за себе у рікбі треба
заслужити повагу каже він
але він безумовно занепокоєний
зростанням випадків насильства і
застосуванням зброї у січні в цьому суші
Барі на півдні Стокгольма застрелили
хлопця і стрілку і жертві було всього по
15 років шведська поліція занепокоєна
таким розвитком подій і все більш
розгублено
ми маємо справу з дедалі молодшими
людьми
деякими з них лише 13 чи 14 років Ми
намагаємося втрутитися повідомляючи
службу у справах дітей зв'язуючись із
батьками або відвідуючи їх вдома але в
якийсь момент ви вже не можете
достукатися до цих молодих людей
ультраправа партія шведські демократи
використовує це насильство для
розпалювання настроїв проти мігрантів у
Швеції
міст Стефана ліндстрома також опинився
на лінії вогню право радикали хочуть
його знести вони вважають що він принесе
злочинність Рігбі ворсвік
Ми зв'язалися з партією шеде але вони
відмовились давати коментарі
знесення мосту було б абсолютно
безглуздим це обійшлося платникам
податків у суму еквівалентну 10
мільйонів євро
це безумство
мало хто переймається тим що насильство
серед молоді може перекинутись на них
через новий міст більшість людей доволі
спокійно ставиться до тієї суперечки
роздули цю проблему до абсурду тут у
цьому районі Я взагалі не помітив
ніякого конфлікту
А перед тим як побудувати міст урінкві
відкрили нову поліцейську дільницю
відтоді там стало набагато спокійніше
Стефан ліндстроум упевнений що міст
матиме позитивний ефект а він
сподівається що сутички вщухнуть коли
міст нарешті буде завершено
для соціальної згуртованості Краще коли
люди із різних верств населення
зустрічаються у повсякденному житті а не
коли є один район для бідних один для
середнього класу і один для багатих Це
нікому не допомагає
за кілька тижнів міст відкриють для
громадськості тоді багато мешканців
рінкбі та урсвіта зустрінуться вперше На
церемонії перерізання стрічки на мосту
А зараз ми подивимось тільки kind з
Німеччини в неї хвороба Паркінсона
невиліковне неврологічне захворювання
багато людей які отримують такий діагноз
замикається в собі і стають самотніми
тільки зробила все навпаки і навіть
наважилося на щось нове а саме насінний
теніс вона настільки добре грає що тепер
бере участь у турнірах коли вона за
столом то майже забуває що в неї хвороба
Паркінсона який багато інших пацієнтів
які тренуються разом з нею зірки
насолоджуються найздоровішою формою
суперництва
[оплески]
секція спінпонку
для маркінсона
у Міда на заході Німеччини щотижня тут
зустрічається 10 гравців із цієї
хворобою
це ритуал із звільнення від щоденної
рутини при хворобі Паркінсона коли тобі
постійно нагадують Що тобі важко
пересуватися
ти потрапляєш в абсолютно Новий світ де
все що тебе оточує відходить на задній
план
зірка кінд 56 років 10 із яких вона живе
з хворобою Паркінсона при цій хворобі
мозок більше не може добре контролювати
рухи тіла тіло стає повільнішим скутішим
з’являється мимовільне тремтіння
[оплески]
але фізичні вправи можуть допомогти і
дуже важливо приймати Дофамін це
речовина месенджер яка передає сигнали
між нервовими клітинами мозку у
пацієнтів із хворобою Паркінсона його
виробляється занадто мало
Я приймаю Дофамін кожні 2 години І це
дуже важливо бо інакше моя енергія
вичерпується машина не може їхати без
пального а я нічого не можу робити без
дофаміну зірка кінд працює волонтеркою в
організації пінк-понк Паркінсон вона
координує величезну мережу-тренувальних
груп по всій Німеччині це дуже багато
роботи Усе більше людей приєднується до
неї зокрема і фузі
фолькмар преантин тут уже вдруге
pin-конг Паркінсон був порадою його
невропатолога
Я гадаю що саме в цьому суть що ти
більше не думаєш про тремтіння індидія
все ще тремчу навіть граючи зараз але
вже після Другої третьої гри це
проходить
зірки переконана що настільний теніс
може сповільнити прогресування хвороби
Паркінсона але науково ще не доведено що
ця гра може допомогти із цим
захворюванням мозку
Ви постійно вирішуєте як прийняти м'яч
Як відбити його і куди ним поцілити
у мозку відбувається багато розумових
процесів
тренування тому що воно тримає мозок у
постійному русі
її щотижневий Санс фізіотерапії повністю
зосереджений на рівновазі та поставі усе
що напружується із горблюється протягом
дня Розкрийте це
і вгору вгору
рух дуже важливий для пацієнтів і
хворобою Паркінсона
їм потрібно багато рухатися щоб
підтримувати організм тонусі і затримати
фізичну дегенерацію на якомога довший
час
навіть після десяти років хвороби зірки
постійно доводиться пристосовуватись до
хвороби Паркінсона дрібні рухи даються
їй важко
Я відчуваю себе пілотом у літаку який
постійно падає вниз а потім знову
здіймається вгору і мені постійно
доводиться відновлювати рівновагу щоб
отримати літак у повітрі
отримала хворобу Паркінсона у 46 років
незвично рано для неї цей діагноз став
несподіванкою
спочатку у мене були моменти суцільної
паніки Я думала про сходи в нашому
будинку якими я не зможу підніматися і
про те що ми повинні готуватися до цього
у мене були панічні атаки через це
чоловік зірки Крістоф зазвичай
тримається спокійно коли мова заходить
про хворобу Паркінсона вони одружені вже
майже 30 років у них двоє дорослих дітей
з віком у кожної людини з'являються
обмеження я на 10 років старший за неї і
помічаю що вже не можу робити ті чи інші
речі звісно у якийсь момент може
знадобитися інвалідний візок але
невідомо Хто з нас опиниться у візку
швидше Ще Побачимо хто кого возитиме я
взагалі розраховував що моя жінка буде
возити мене робіть ставки зараз
але зараз тільки знову за столом для
пінг-понгу цього разу на турнірі у
вайсвасері на сході Німеччини зірки грає
на всіх змаганнях
[оплески]
це знову і знову Показує мені що
незважаючи на хворобу Все можливо і
можна досягти високих результатів звісно
все має бути ідеально та іноді хвороба
Паркінсона стає на заваді але з цим
треба навчитися жити не розчаровуватися
і йти вперед незважаючи ні на що багато
гравців приводять на турніри своїй сім'ї
тут у спортивному залі Вся суть у
спільноті якби у мене не було цієї
хвороби Я б не відчувала всього цього
відчуття спільноти І не зустріла б усіх
цих людей це справжній герой буденності
Вони вміють справлятися зі своєю долею і
при цьому бути щасливими а вони всі для
мене приклади для наслідування
в них пункт Паркінсон дав тільки та
багатьом іншим тут нове життя
це спосіб вигравати маленькі битви у
війні із невиліковною хворобою
[оплески]
Уявіть собі короля Чарльза та його
дружину Камілу які сидять вдома За
філіжанкою чаю чай може бути звідки
завгодно а філіжанки швидше за все вони
з Угорщини
перселяновим майстерня херен одне з
найвідоміших європейських міст де
виготовляють посуд і зручним розписом
королівські особи зірки заможні та
відомі люди полюбляють цінню угорські
вироби і скільки вони користуються таким
попитом люди в херенді працюють не
покладаючи рук
Дякую але я краще обійдуся дешевими
керамічними горнятками на випадок якщо
їх впущу але сьогодні це все дякуємо за
перегляд Бережіть себе і до зустрічі за
тиждень вступному випуску У фокусі
Європа
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]